efore this is a two-minute er if you
weren't around for any of the
tournament's yet on the stream if you're
completely new to the stream it's going
to be much faster than what you're
seeing here ok so we know our advanced
variation of the French if you're not
familiar with this pawn structure
probably shouldn't be getting involved
with this and I don't know if I'm really
in a position to get your file with it
I'm not super familiar with it turns out
to being quite their strategic type of a
game out of the French here I have to be
concerned about maybe the queen or the
bishop playing to a 4 that's something
that I emphasized in a fairly recent
video I think one of the game analysis
ones anyhow a4 i think is the right idea
doesn't allow for the queen or bishop to
play here maybe this square available
let's go h4 h5 if i could get h6 in
that's going to be a very good thing
main reason for it is that the bishop
can get to this g 5 square my opponent
is clearly stopping that idea my bishop
can be kicked away and actually I'm
going to run forward with this or should
I keep the night away I okay push here
g4 I'm going to try this actually and
then
look up and over bishop here seems right
we could be I know wait a second I could
have just captured here capture here and
Link at d5 this is a an opening i played
in one of the live blitz games it wasn't
a game analysis i had a pond right there
i missed that ah ok well now it's very
difficult cuz my night is a fool right
here what is even going to do i just had
pawn takes pawn Oh missing stuff let's
come over here this is no good I really
have anything this night is going to
come to see for it's so strong I need to
get rid of it we're going to put an
opposite color bishop ending I cannot
push this Bishop away and my opponent
has play on this file I better create
some sort of an inbound before this file
comes out opened to the rooks I'm going
to run with that and again I need to be
in a spot to play Knight d2 this night
gets here and is allowed to sit there
for any amount of time that could be a
big problem so I'm hitting c5 and what
else
hmm
ok
it's double up the rooks little time
left and adults hitting the rook or I'm
hitting the night guess just rook here
sleep my queen in clean right here okay
let's grab a pond no time left or to be
seven actually stuff is falling now tie
pressure there is Knight takes pawn here
by the way with an in-between move to
follow up Knight takes Knight but no
time left alright good game let's back
up if I'm to throw out one quick point
it's maybe we're right here actually I
don't know if you really need to play
this b6 move is that really needed maybe
your queen wants to play here I guess
it's okay to just support c5 there's got
to be another point this h6 move is good
keep that in mind those of you on this
right here you can't have to be super
cautious about weakening your dark
squares and h6 is a threat to secure the
g5 square for the white pieces so keep
that in mind and right here I should
have just actually captured right here
before playing r up there I think
capture this is a big adjustment because
this sets the tone for the rest of the
game right here instead of rook c8
capture on d4 have me recapture and only
then play up to see 8 and only then play
your night to a five and then c4 look to
double on the C file I have absolutely
no play the only possibility I'm really
seeing is a tactical one may be against
h6 bishop and queen forming a battery
but I think that's easily met with King
h7 preventing any of that type of a
sacrifice bishop or extremely a minor
piece for
coupons type of situation so go with
that just switch the move order take
here first and then rook c8 Knight a5
double up on the C file this becomes a
great liability my sepan